it's an incredibly important state to
the prosperity of this country uh we're
the saudi arabia of the united states
we're the largest coal producer or the
largest toronto producer uh we're one of
the top oil and gas producers in the
nation we really are in instrumental in
terms of ensuring prosperity in this
country
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
u.s congressional candidate for
wyoming's at-large district harriet
hageman welcome to the reuben report
thank you so much for having me dave
it's wonderful to be here
i'm glad to have you because we met
briefly about two weeks ago at a
fundraiser at peter thiel's house and
you were going to give a talk and then
unfortunately sometimes it does rain
here
in miami and it started to rain so you
had to cut your talk just a bit short
but i thought there's something
interesting this lady's up to something
i liked what you started talking about
you're running against liz cheney
there's a lot there
so i thought first off how about you
just introduce yourself uh to the people
since uh you know wyoming obviously a
small state but an important one but for
the people that don't know you
well i appreciate that opportunity yes i
was going to give a bit more background
about who i was it was a wonderful event
at peter's home and so many of the
people there had never met me before so
i wanted to give them just a bit of
background so that they knew who they
were supporting and why we oftentimes
focus on the fact that i'm running
against liz cheney but i'm not just
running against liz cheney i'm running
for wyoming i have deep deep roots in
wyoming i my great grandfather came to
wyoming in 1879 on a cattle trail north
from texas and he ended up ranching
there for
many many years and so i have lots of
cousins i have a very large family here
in wyoming and then i come from a large
family myself when i was born i was my
parents fifth child uh when they brought
me home from the hospital my oldest
sister was five years old
and they had just bought a ranch they
were over two hundred thousand dollars
in debt they had 35 dollars in the bank
and it was 1962. so we were we were land
rich i guess you'd say but awfully cash
poor i grew up on that ranch i grew up
fixing fence and moving cows and
flipping bales and doing whatever was
necessary we all learned to drive when
we were about four years old because we
helped our dad when he was feeding cows
we were very actively involved and our
parents ensured that we were and one of
the things that they always taught us
when we were growing up and i know that
this sounds a bit strange to some people
who don't grow up in that kind of a life
but my parents always told us that we
had we had a responsibility to keep
ourselves alive from the time we were
very very young three and four years old
we were told we had to keep ourselves
alive they didn't put a lot of
constraints on us we we rode horseback
uh we did things we would be gone from
the house you know for six seven hours a
day we played with snapping turtles we
had a rattlesnake that lived under the
house for a period of time we did a lot
of things out there but we but with that
we had a lot of freedom i guess is what
i'm saying and so the flip side of
freedom is responsibility and the flip
side of responsibility is freedom and
right now in this country that isn't
really the way that people view things
and i think thomas seoul recently said
it best when he said people are no
longer responsible for themselves but
they're responsible for what other
people did
even if it was a hundred years ago and i
think that that's where we're heading in
this country and i think it's a really
wrong approach and i think that that's
why my background really helps me to
understand because that freedom is
incredibly important and is part of why
i'm running so in terms of my background
you know i'm a water and natural
resource attorney i'm a constitutional
attorney i've been practicing law for
almost 33 years and i've been fighting
for and working for wyoming for a long
long time i work and i fight for the
people who put food on your table gas in
your car a roof over your head and they
pave your highways and so i have the
credentials i have the background i have
the knowledge about wyoming
to be an effective congresswoman for the
state but also you mentioned that
wyoming is an important state it's an
incredibly important state to the
prosperity of this country we're the
saudi arabia of the united states where
the largest coal producer or the largest
toronto producer uh we're one of the top
oil and gas producers in the nation we
really are in instrumental in terms of
ensuring prosperity in this country and
so that's why it is so incredibly
important to have someone with my
background my history and my knowledge
running for this seat because i need to
do it for wyoming and i also need to do
it for our country
you know it's funny you said it quite
well there but when i was listening to
you talk at peter's i was thinking this
is really something because you were
saying a little bit about your bio and
i'm thinking here i am i'm brooklyn born
lived in new york city most of my life
then los angeles for you know the last
eight years until i moved here to the
free state of florida and yet the things
that you're talking about right now are
exactly the things that resonate with me
and that shows you how the ideas of
freedom and liberty and all of that
crazy stuff really has nothing to do
with geography people just don't
understand the issues so one thing that
i saw and i didn't know this until this
morning when i was doing a little
research on you that uh wyoming's at
large district meaning there is only one
congressional district in the entire
state that that is really is that the
only state to have that i think so
i think so and we're the least populated
state in the nation so we only have 560
000 people in our state but we're the
ninth largest land wise
so i've already traveled since september
i've already driven over 13 000 miles in
the state of wyoming visiting every
single county sometimes multiple times
going to events last wednesday i was at
a bowl sale in warland and
meeting with our ranchers meeting with
our cattle producers talking to them
about the challenges associated with the
supply chain oh my goodness gracious
trying to get parts for our tractors
trying to get parts for our trucks to be
able to haul our livestock all of those
things are being impacted by this
horrific administration that we have in
place right now with joe biden nancy
pelosi and the radical democrats we feel
it in wyoming you feel it in new york
you feel it in florida we feel it
everywhere in this country because this
is a disaster that has been created in
large part because the very first thing
that
biden did when he took office was try to
choke off our energy supply that affects
me personally in wyoming because again
we're an energy producing state but
affects every single one of us and just
i've been having to eat out quite a bit
lately because i am traveling so much
the cost of food in restaurants is
absolutely skyrocketing i had a
breakfast the other day at the airport
realized it's been expensive at the
airport a pork chop couple of eggs a a
cup of coffee a cup of tea
um it's 33
now that's just astronomical and it is
because of this administration so you
mentioned that you guys are an energy
producing state obviously can you just
talk a little bit about the type of
people that are in that line of work the
people that are in in the coal mines et
cetera et cetera that are that are doing
this stuff because i think people
especially out of the mainstream left
now what you get at aoc and the rest of
them is just a complete dismissal of
these people and their lives and the
work that they do and how you know you
mentioned generational uh how many years
they've put into this and everything
else can you talk about the types of
people that are your hopeful
constituents
absolutely they are the salt of the
earth they're independent they're tough
they know who and what we are in the
state of wyoming they understand our
constitution and they really do
understand freedom and liberty because
they live it every day
uh they do what they want to do and they
produce a fabulous resource so many
people want to write cool off and say
that coal is an energy of the past
that's absolutely stupid and it's stupid
for a lot of reasons one is coal is
abundant it's clean it is accessible
it's affordable uh it is absolutely an
energy of the future and we are the
largest coal producer in the nation uh
the japan china they're building
coal-fired power plants like there's no
tomorrow uh the reality is is that we
have to have fossil fuels or people are
gonna die they're gonna die in the
summer from heat they're gonna die in
the winter from cold and that's why
i'm very proud of what wyoming does
because we make everybody's lives better
when you flip on that switch there's an
awfully good chance that that
electricity is coming from my state
because it's coming from our coal if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell